[Musique]
voici greenberg la fille de saison qui a
commencé les grèves pour le climat suivi
un peu partout en europe et elle a dit
aux responsables européens aux
dirigeants européens
nous savons que la plupart des
responsables politiques ne veulent pas
discuter avec nous bon nous ne voulons
pas discuter avec eux non plus nous
voulons qu'ils parlent à la communauté
scientifique
ben je fais partie de la communauté
scientifique et je me suis donc dit
qu'est ce que je dirais bien aux
politiciens
en fait tous les partis politiques
trouvent le climat super important et
c'est logique pourquoi le climat est
important il suffit de penser aux
sécheresses aux innovations à la montée
des mers que le futur nous réserve
c'est plus difficile de comprendre
pourquoi alors n'avançons nous pas plus
vite avec notre politique climatique et
donc j'ai décidé d'organiser mon ma
présentation autour de cette fausse
bonne idée sur le climat cette idée qui
selon moi freine une politique
climatique un efficace et ambitieuse et
voici la première la forêt amazonienne
absorbent le co2 en fait il la forêt
amazonienne et mais la même quantité de
co2 vie à la respiration des arbres des
champignons et 1b des bactéries en fait
tu n'es qu'un hectare de forêt
amazonienne vierge c'est comme un puits
de carbone à l' équilibre et c'est
généralement le cas de nos forêts
lorsqu'on va considérer que le carbone
qui quitte la forêt afia le bois un jour
ou l'autre retourne à l'atmosphère sous
forme de co2
les boissons très important néanmoins
parce que la déforestation mais augmente
les émissions et inversément la
reforestation va absorber du co2 de
l'atmosphère
il faut donc massivement reboiser notre
planète mais en même temps il faut
comprendre que la présence des forêts ne
permet pas de compenser les émissions
des combustibles fossiles
voici donc ma deuxième fausse bonne idée
une émission d'une tonne de co2 augmente
la température durant des décennies
ben en fait c'est beaucoup plus
longtemps
imaginez une émission de son gigatonnes
aujourd'hui et regardez ici l'effet sur
la température durant les siècles à
venir et on voit donc après milan nous
avons toujours un effet de 2000 degrés
celsius par gigatonnes pourquoi cet
effet à très longtemps en fait imaginer
que mon corps c'est représentent les
sons gigatonnes de co2 qui quitte la
cheminée aujourd'hui après dix ans j'ai
dit pour cent de mon corps qui sera
absorbée par les couches supérieures de
l'océan après un siècle l'océan à
absorber la moitié de mon corps et il
faut 1000 ans avant que 75% de du co2
soit absorbée par les couches profondes
de l'océan et le dernier quart ne sera
jamais absorbés par ce que la terre aura
trouvé un nouvel équilibre avec plus de
co2 dont lapin dans l'atmosphère est
plus de ces de co2 dont l'un dans les
océans
alors se pose la question s'il ya un
effet à très long terme pourquoi n'y at
il pas plus d'effet au début lorsque les
océans n'ont encore rien absorber
pour ajouter du co2 dans l'atmosphère
c'est comme ajouter une couche une
couverture autour de la terre quand vous
allez quand vous allez vous mettre dans
le livre le lit prend du temps à se
réchauffer c'est pour ça que vous êtes
heureux de voir votre partenaire déjà
dans le lit quand vous arrivez comme ça
elle a réchauffé le lit c'est la même
chose avec la terre seulement ce
réchauffement prend des décennies voire
des siècles et c'est pour ça que les
faits en fait est relativement constant
à à travers les siècles
on voit donc que lorsqu'on fait une
analyse coûts avantages sur le climat
ont comparé les coûts pour éviter une
émission aujourd'hui avec un dégât
éternelle si on veut réduire limiter le
réchauffement climatique à un degré et
demi ou deux 2 2 degrés en fait on s'en
fout du moment des émissions la seule
chose qui compte c'est la somme de
toutes les émissions entre maintenant et
le moment qu'on aura arriver à zéro
émission
en fait on peut représenter l'atmosphère
comme une baignoire ton est en train de
remplir et il faut fermer le robinet
avant que la baignoire ne déborde
en conclusion pour stabiliser le climat
il faut aller vers zéro émission parce
que de chaque tonne émise
il y à un car qui ne sera jamais
absorber ni par les maires ni par les
forêts parlons d'économie maintenant
voici ma troisième fausse bonne idée
la politique climatique ne doit pas
toucher au pouvoir d'achat
soyons honnêtes pour aller vers zéro
émission il faut consacrer 1 ou 2% du
pib comme les coups les véritables coûts
sont sensibles le monde politique adore
les win win et win win existe et voici
un exemple
j'ai fait un emprunt à la banque pour
isolément grenier et mes économies au
mazout dépasse mes frais pour rembourser
l'emprunt
je gagne en pouvoir d'achat et je
diminue mes émissions
en fait j'étais en train de jeter
l'argent par la fenêtre ou par le toit
plus précisément et j'ai arrêté de le
faire maintenant ces opportunités où les
gens peuvent arrêter de jeter l'argent
par la fenêtre sont ré vite relativement
limité si vous pensez par exemple par
l'isolation des sols ou des murs d'une
maison existante
ben ce sera pas financièrement rentable
parce que le coût climatique ne se
trouve pas dont le prix du mazout que
vous allez éviter et donc si vous voulez
obtenir ces investissements il faut soit
augmenter le prix du mazout soit
subsidiés ou imposer ses travaux lors de
la revente dans la maison par exemple
et comme ces mesures diminue légèrement
le pouvoir d'achat elles tardent à se
réaliser
en fait tu lis réduire les émissions
c'est comme un investissement
intergénérationnel nous subissons les
frais pour réduire les émissions et les
générations futures en valeur éviter les
dégâts qui sont ailleurs
éternel c'est donc une logique pas une
logique de win win c'est une logique de
solidarité solidarité avec les
générations futures et les pays plus
chaud alors se pose la question comment
peut-on est vraiment alors viennent ma
quatrième une fausse bonne idée qui en
fait l inverse d'un troisième réalisé
une société zéro carbone est extrême
cher je répond évidemment la même chose
1 à 2% du pib
c'est c'est relativement raisonnable par
exemple la sécurité sociale qui suit
également une logique de solidarité
représente 25% du pib belge ces quinze
fois plus que ce qu'il nous faut pour
aller faire sert aux émissions d'autant
plus n'oublions pas question né diminue
pas les émissions on aura des dégâts
climatiques qui peuvent très bien qu'ils
vont probablement dépasser les 2% du pib
et aussi il y a des effets secondaires
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
estime par exemple que la pollution de
l'air tue sept millions de personnes par
an vient alors la question comment
peut-on imposer de réduction d'émissions
aux entreprises et une idée parmi
d'autres c'est de dire imposant un prix
sur la pollution
vient alors la question oui mais les
entreprises vont peut-être juste payer
pour polluer et essayent tout et ça
revient à cette idée que augmenter le
prix les émissions pourraient très peu
d'effet sur ses émissions
en fait on observe linverse regardez ici
les émissions de l'industrie européenne
entre 2005 et 2010 est c'est les
émissions depuis que l'industrie est
régulée par le marché carbone qui a mis
un prix entre 6 et 25 euros la tonne
c'est un prix relativement faible c'est
moins qu'un sainte paris litres
d'essence par exemple et on voit que ces
émissions ont été réduit de 26%
oui mais vous allez me dire saison il y
avait évidemment doutre effet on voit
ici clairement l'effet de la crise 7
pourquoi j'ai nous avons essayé de
estimer l'effet causal de ce marché
carbone dont pour chaque entreprise
régulier nous avons cherché une
entreprise semblables dont le même pays
le même secteur avec un un niveau de
ventes et de profitabilité et
d'émissions comparables
avant 2005 avant le début de notre
régulation et donc ces entreprises
comparables ont aussi connu la crise ont
aussi connu la hausse du prix du pétrole
par exemple seulement elles n'ont pas
été réglés par la marché carbone et ses
entreprises existent parce que par
exemple leurs fours étaient juste en
dessous du seuil pour être inclus dans
le marché carbone et donc en comparant
les entreprises régulé avec leur soeur
semblables on trouve que les fait causal
du marché carbone est une réduction de
10% des émissions et la même idée
s'applique dans d'autres secteurs moi
j'ai des amis dans des discussions avec
des amis et il m'a dit oui mais même si
le décès d' est à 2 euros le litre
moi je dois quand même prendre ma
voiture pour aller au travail et ils ont
raison évidemment c'est probablement le
cas de plusieurs parmi vous regardons
néanmoins ce que les études
scientifiques trouvent à ce sujet voici
un résumé de 43 étude qui trouvent que
une augmentation du prix du carburant de
10 % à long terme diminue la
consommation de 8 % comme estimation
moyenne
il ya des études qui trouve un effet
plus faibles ou en effet plus élevé mais
c'est jamais 0%
notons aussi que si mon prix augmentent
de 10% et j'ai réduit ma consommation
demi pour cent mon budget total n'a
augmenté que de 2 % et seulement
j'aurais probablement un moteur plus
efficace une voiture plus petite
je vais peut-être quelques kilomètres en
moins
1 lorsqu'on parle du prix du carburant
vient souvent sur la table alors la
fausse bonne idée suivante une taxe sur
les émissions et analysera toujours
davantage les personnes à faible revenu
en fait ça dépend ça dépend de la
manière dont la taxe a été utilisé
disons d'abord que il est très important
de mesurer l'effet de la politique
climatique sur l'inégalité parce que
souvent il ya un souci imaginez une
personne avec un revenu faible de 1000
euros par mois qu'ils dépensent 400
euros en logements et une autre personne
avait qu'un haut revenu de 4000 euros
par mois qu'ils dépensent 800 euros en
les chemins en logements imaginons un
gouvernement qui impose un niveau
d'isolation très performant qui augmente
le coût des logements de 5 %
ça représente 2 % du revenu du bas
revenus tandis que seulement 1% du
revenu plus élevé
votre technologie verte a augmenté
l'inégalité et ce sera généralement le
cas ce sera souvent le cas parce que les
technologies vertes s'applique à des
biens comme l'énergie qui représente une
part relatif plus importants dont les
uns dépenses des parvenus
imaginons maintenant que les mêmes y de
la même génération et le résultat
indirect d'une taxe sur le co2 imaginons
à nouveau que la personne riche ici
dépense deux fois plus en masse au titre
que la personne à revenus faibles une
taxe de 20% sur le mazout à nouveau va
représenter 2 % du revenu faible tandis
que ce n'est que 1 % du revenu plus
élevé
né au moins pour la taxe se pose la
question qu'est ce que le gouvernement
fait avec les revenus de la taxe et on
peut s'imaginer que le gouvernement et
l'envi de redistribuer les revenus des
taxes de manière égale imaginons une
forme des éco chèques et chaque personne
reçoit le même nombre d'éco chèques
nous avons ici donc 60 euros de revenus
de taxes chaque personne reçoit 30 euros
de chèques climat et donc on voit que
grâce à la taxe et le recyclage que la
personne à faible revenu a gagné
augmenter son pouvoir d'achat de 10
euros et à augmenter l'égalité le moteur
derrière ce résultat c'est que même si
le mazout ici représente une part plus
importants dont le budget faible en
termes absolus la personne riche à émet
plus de co2 et le gouvernement peut
encore faire mieux
par exemple lorsque les bas revenus vont
recevoir une part plus qu égale 2 2 la
taxe on peut s'imaginer une réduction de
taxes sur le travail peu qualifié
par exemple je suis alors arrivé à ma 7e
fausse bonne idée qui dit que la seule
chose qu'il nous faut pour une société
zéro carbone c'est les nouvelles
technologies en fait les nouvelles
technologies vertes sont très importants
pour la société zéro carbone mais il
faut se demander la question pourquoi
n'avons nous n'avons nous pas les
politiques qui vont mener au
développement de ces technologies et
donc je vous ai dit que la paix là le
climat est une question de solidarité
tout comme la sécurité sociale la
sécurité sociale a été le résultat de
solidarité d'altruisme d'un sentiment
d'inclusion et plus
pourtant encore un résultat de luttes
des gens qui ont combattu pour un idéal
permettez moi donc de finir avec une
note d'optimisme depuis trois ans le
gouvernement wallon a un comité d
experts du climat que je préside le
décret kelly main impose une réduction
des émissions de 95 % en 2050
depuis trois ans nous écrivons donc des
rapports alarmants
sans réponse de la part des ministres
sauf maintenant que les jeunes se
trouvent dans les rues toutes les
semaines nous avons été auditionné par
le parlement
donc grâce au jeu un sens les jeunes
nous en tant qu'expert on n'a pas
d'effet merci aux jeunes en résumé voici
mais sec bonne idée pour le climat il
faut dès à présent avoir une vision de
long terme vous revenez vers zéro
émission y consacrer 1 2% du pib
il faut revoir notre système d'impôts
pour que les impôts diminuent les
émissions et diminue l'inégalité en même
temps et il faut se mobiliser pour la
solidarité avec les générations futures
générations futures qui malheureusement
ne peuvent pas voter
mais les jeunes qui n'ont pas de droit
de vote comme comme les générations
futures ont quand même pu bouger les
lignes
merci à eux merci à vous de m'avoir
écouté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et